99 of AI startups are going to fail over
the next 24 months the enormous amount
of checks and money and time and energy
people are going to put into AI
companies where the decision maker a
doesn't even understand the technology
as well as they'd like to think and B
doesn't realize that almost all of them
are commoditized and that the people
that are actually going to win are going
to be far more based on the operators
that drive the cars and the cars that
they're building no dependent sports
cards sports cards or art are good
Investments the problem is for the 7 to
50 people in this town 80 years ago that
were smart and bought Jackson Pollock
there was thousands of other people that
bought Jackson schmalek and lost a ton
of money yeah Michael Jordan's rookie
card is worth a lot of money but 99 of
athletes are not 99 of AI startups are
going to fail